- [Kelly] You're a new
book is full of stories
about cool musicians.
Like when your daughter, this is amazing.
Your daughter had her like,
basically her first piano lesson
from Paul McCartney.
What is your life?
- It's really weird.
That's what the book is
about, how weird my life is.
- [Kelly] This is why I didn't
think you would remember me.
Because, Paul McCartney taught
your daughter to play piano.
- [Dave] I was going to put
you in the book and then they.
- [Kelly] I didn't allow it.
- [Dave] It wouldn't fit, it
wouldn't fit next book that
the sequel.
- [Kelly] I was like, oh
my God, that's amazing,
and your daughter had no idea
how cool that moment was.
- No, so I grew up, the
Beatles were my favorite band
and still are.
And so when I was young,
I didn't take lessons to play music,
I just had Beatles records
and a Beatles song but,
years later I wound up
meeting Paul McCartney.
And over time we played music
together, we became friends.
He really is like the sweetest,
Most lovely-
Friends with the Beatles!
Okay, keep going-
It's crazy.
And, and I never forget that.
Like, he's the nicest guy
in the world, but you know,
every once in a while it
clicks, you're like, "oh my God,
I'm sitting with a Beatle right now,
I'm sitting with a Beatle".
- [Kelly] He is super nice though,
so I met him once very quickly,
we were in the same studio,
like doing stuff and in passing,
he was so sweet.
- So when, when my third
daughter Ophelia was born,
he was in town, he was like,
"Hey, we want to come see the baby".
And so they came over to the house,
and we had pizza, we're drinking wine.
- With Paul McCartney.
Listen! you never realize how
much Beatles stuff you have
in your house.
- Until your embarrassed.
- Until a Beatle comes home.
And then you're like hiding everything,
you're like, "oh my God,
there's a coffee table books"
- Don't look like a tool
don't look like a tool.
- Flipping out.
And so as he was leaving,
there's a piano near the
front door and he sits down,
and he just starts playing Lady Madonna.
In my living room!
I'm like, "Oh my God".
And so he's like playing.
And my daughter Harper
goes into the kitchen,
and she grabs a coffee cup and
she puts some change in it,
and puts it on the piano
like it's a tip jar.
- No!
- I was like.
- That's amazing.
- And then she sits down next to him,
and she had never played piano before,
and he starts showing her like,
here's the C and these are the notes.
And the two of them sat
down and started playing,
and they wrote a song together.
And that was her first lesson.
- Oh my gosh, that's so much cooler
than anything my kids have done.
(audience laughing)
(Clapping)
- Like what!
That's incredible